Speaker 1: So G.B. News spent days promoting
a supposedly blockbuster, incredible, groundbreaking
interview with Donald Trump, conducted by
British politician and broadcaster Nigel Farage.
And I have to tell you, this is one of the
most bonkers off the wall interviews I've
ever seen Trump do. It's essentially 100 percent
an interview about cultural issues like cancel
culture. And what does Trump think about Meghan
Markle and Tearfund? Black Lives Matter comes
up in this first clip. And even right off
the bat here, Trump jumping right into police
related stuff, which is just crazy because
police were attacked by his supporters on
January 6th. No mention or support of those
officers, but plenty of mentions of it was
actually Antifa and BLM who did bad stuff.
Take a look at this just off the wall alternate
reality.
Speaker 4: Now, either way, we've got Biden
and Harris in office, and they've got plummeting
poll ratings and we got a border crisis. As
you quite rightly said.
Speaker 1: Remember Plumb, everything here
is sort of a lie. Plummeting poll ratings
still higher than Trump and the border crisis,
where essentially nothing has really changed
since Trump left
Speaker 4: law and order the Black Lives Matter
movement, which is now becoming increasingly,
I think, political time. You know, it's shocking
that it started off, you know, with pigs in
a blanket, right? You know that right? You
know, the expression fry them like bacon.
And they were always about our police, our
great police and all of
Speaker 1: the great police where Trump doesn't
say anything about the police that were tased
and et cetera, on January six by his supporters.
Speaker 4: This becomes mainstream. I don't
really think so. And antifa bad. Very bad,
bad. And they had antifa in that rally. They
had antifa leading a lot of people on that
day on January.
Speaker 1: No evidence of that whatsoever.
Speaker 4: And I will say that it's pretty
incredible that nothing happens to them, but
the other side, this has been going on for
many years.
Speaker 1: There is no evidence that Antifa
individuals committed crimes on January 6th.
That's why there are no cases against them.
Speaker 4: They don't just about they're not
just about racial equality, though. Well,
I think they're about politics, but I think
they are about a lot of other things. If you
go back to their original founding and what
they were saying, kill the police. What they're
saying is kill the police and that becomes
mainstream. Not good.
Speaker 1: Not good, says Donald Trump. Next
clip Donald Trump claims that now we aren't
globally respected anymore. We have objective
data about that. The US reputation was lower
than ever under Trump. It has now recovered
to some degree under Biden. Is Biden perfect?
No. Is his foreign policy the stuff of dreams?
No. But by every measure, the U.S. is more
respected now than under Trump. But Trump
doesn't care.
Speaker 4: Biden, G7 Biden turns up at the
G7 and this was before he let everybody down
in Afghanistan. And which leaves us wondering,
where is America in the world now? I mean,
we've got big threats. We've got a lot of
Russian troops on the Ukrainian border. We've
got China ever more bellicose in their statements
about Taiwan. We've got Iran. I mean, can
you believe it? Negotiations are going on
this week with Iran and the Israelis and the
Israelis are very, very scared. Where is America
in the world right now? I think it's at the
lowest point it's ever been at.
Speaker 1: There is no objective way to defend
that statement. It is objectively a lie.
Speaker 4: I don't think it's ever been in
a position like this. We're not respected
anymore. I will tell you there were no planes
flying over Taiwan and the name wasn't even
mentioned. You didn't talk about Taiwan when
I was president. It wasn't going to happen
what they're doing now.
Speaker 1: Trump knows nothing about Taiwan.
That's why he wasn't talking about it
Speaker 4: and then wait till after the Olympics,
I assume. And perhaps something will happen,
but it's not good of you there and you have
bombers flying over here.
Speaker 1: So Trump just wrong. There is the
reputation of the U.S. has started to recover.
It's not perfect. It's not perfect. But it
is start. It was at the bottom under Trump,
where Trump wasn't even party to many important
global discussions, including on climate,
as we've mentioned before. OK. Next clip In
this one, Trump says something. Let's see
if we can figure out what it is, even that
Trump is saying here.
Speaker 4: I'm not a fan of hers at all. Oh,
I think she's right.
Speaker 1: This is the Meghan Markle clip.
In this clip, Trump says he's not a fan of
Meghan Markle. OK.
Speaker 4: I'm not a fan of hers at all, and
I think she's very disrespectful to the Queen.
We just spoke about, yeah, who's such a great
woman who such a great person, but a historic
person? I think she's very disrespectful to
the royal family, but maybe most importantly,
to the Queen.
Speaker 1: And what's wild about this is,
you know, Meghan Markle and her husband, one
of the princes. I don't I don't care about
the royals. They made a decision together,
right? I mean, about separating from this
kind of traditional life of the royal family.
But Trump's not a fan of Meghan Markle specifically.
Kind of just all very weird. Then here's a
strange clip Trump says something was a big
mistake. Let's see if we can figure out what
it is that Trump says was a big mistake.
Speaker 4: I heard you through, I guess, through
Twitter. It was was for you. You know, some
of the used to massive effect. Oh, Jack Dorsey
is being removed as CEO of Twitter because
of shareholder pressure, but whether that
means they'll improve as a channel or not.
And I was amazed the day that the Taliban
you mentioned Afghanistan a moment ago, the
day the Taliban took over Kabul. I did put
out a message that said it seemed ridiculous
that their leadership was still active on
Twitter. And yet you were still bad. Well,
they were wrong and what they did and are
dealing with the United States president,
who's obviously a pop.
Speaker 1: So when he says they were wrong,
is he talking about the Taliban or Twitter?
Like, it's not totally clear to me,
Speaker 4: President Trump, based on everything
that you see and them and Facebook, and I
think they made a big mistake. I think if
they had
Speaker 1: OK, I guess he's saying if Twitter
and Facebook had a do over about banning him,
I think over
Speaker 4: again they wouldn't be doing it.
We are, you know, we get the voice out. We
have to do it. We have an obligation to do
that. But he's leaving. I guess it was probably
in force because they're down. And also there's
no excitement on Twitter anymore.
Speaker 1: OK, so I guess he's saying Jack
Dorsey is leaving because Twitter isn't doing
so well. So just very, you know, what are
you talking about, dude? Trump is asked about
2024. He seems to be signaling that he is
running.
Speaker 4: Why on earth would he consider
going back into that hall again? So I love
our country. I brought the country to a level
it's never seen before. Right. And we had
COVID come in and then I brought it back,
came up with vaccines that you're using. We're
all using the world is using saved tens of
millions of people throughout the world.
Speaker 1: So now he's for the vaccines
Speaker 4: in less than nine months who are
supposed to take 12 years
Speaker 1: now. It was never supposed to take
12 years. We knew from the start these vaccines
would be based on an MRA platform. The platform
had been researched for decades. Nobody thought
what Trump is saying is there are times in
history where the development of some vaccines
could take 10 to 12 years, often six to eight.
Nobody ever thought it was going to take 12
years with the mRNA vaccines you just
Speaker 4: heard the other day. They were
expecting it to take 12 years and everyone
said it wasn't going to work and they work
incredibly well. We've done an amazing job.
If you love the country, you have no choice.
It's not a question. Is this this is a wonderful,
beautiful life. But I like that too, because
I was helping people. That's why I did it.
And I think you'll be happy in the future,
too.
Speaker 1: So Trump began with this idea of
if you love the country, you got to run. And
I think you're going to be happy in the future.
He seems to be signaling he's going to be
running. And then finally, no Trump interview
is complete without Trump bragging about the
size of his crowds.
Speaker 4: So looking ahead, you know from
here is the message to look back at November
2020 and to condemn and criticize much of
what happened. Or is the message to look forward
and try and make sure that that that that
weakness in the system can't exist? And I
think it's both. I think it has to be worth
it. We have a base in Alabama as an example
of sixty nine thousand people recently show
up wherever I go. We get I think I'm getting
bigger crowds now at the rallies and, you
know, the rallies and they've been to plenty.
I I have the biggest crowds I've ever had
Speaker 1: when, he says now, by the way,
he when he hasn't done a rally in months and
months and months. So a wacky, wacky interview.
But the big takeaways Trump still bragging
about the same stuff without any basis, and
he seems to be leaning towards running
in 2024.